- Hello everyone.
It's so wonderful to see you
all at this first convening
of the semester in the virtual world.
First, I hope you and your
families are all staying well
in these unusually challenging times.
And as per tradition,
I want to acknowledge
that we are grateful to the Quinnipiac,
the Wappinger and the Paugussett people
as we stand on their land, virtually.
Keeping in the spirit of recognizing,
I would also like to take
this opportunity to thank
Richard and Barbara
Franke for the generosity
in establishing the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities
at Yale that enables our activities.
I'm utterly delighted that
they are here this evening.
I think they are on, and they
are joining us from Arizona.
So here's a brief preview
of coming attractions
for this semester is activities
for the Franke Program before
we delve into today's treat.
So please mark your calendars.
We've sent everyone save the date.
Dan Esty will be giving a talk
on October 15th, and then we have
Kim Stanley Robinson who will be giving
a talk on 18th November.
And we have Frank Snowden who will
be talking to us on December 2nd.
So moving on to today's wonderful event.
I'm absolutely delighted to invite you all
to first talk of the
season by one of our own,
a very distinguished faculty member,
Professor Valerie Hansen.
Professor Hansen is a
Stanley Woodward Professor
of History and her research focus has been
on China before 1600, Chinese religious
and legal history and the
history of the Silk Road.
She's the acclaimed author of
several books that include,
previous books that include
"The Silk Road: A New History,"
"The Open Empire, A
History of China to 1600,"
"Negotiating Daily Life
in Traditional China,"
"Changing Gods in Medieval China,"
and "Voyages in World History."
She has written numerous essays, chapters,
translated many scholarly
books and journals.
She is an authority on China before 1600,
and in particular has really focused
beyond China in trying
to understand transfer,
and the history of what
we now call globalization,
the history of the process,
and how peoples coming
together have impacted each
other's ways of thinking
and the view of the world.
So during the pandemic,
I usually have been
waking up to BBC Radio Four,
and a couple of months
ago I heard her voice,
which I recognized, talking
about her fascinating new book
and was so utterly
delighted when she accepted
our invitation to speak
at the Franke Program.
So she recently published a book called
"The Year 2000, When Globalization Began,"
which looks at the impact of travelers
who visited unfamiliar locales,
the early adventurers and explorers,
and opening up all the land and sea routes
that mark the true
beginning of globalization.
So she's got to talk to us.
In this book, she has focused on travelers
before the so-called age of exploration.
So these are really the
pioneers who in a way,
joined the world together.
She, a brief biography before
I cede the floor to her.
She joined the Yale faculty
as an Assistant Professor
of History in 1988, and the
breadth of her intellectual
interest is the course
titles that she teaches
and I urge you to go and take a look.
She has won many, many honors
and is recognized for her expertise.
Her most recent honors
include the 2013 Gustav Ranis
International Book Prize for the best book
on an international subject by
a member of the Yale faculty
and the 2013 International Convention
of Asia Scholars Book Prize
Reading Committee Accolade
for the best teaching
tool in the humanities.
And I'm sure that this book is going
to be gathering accolades.
It has just come out.
So Valerie, here's to you.
Thank you so much for coming once again.
- Thanks so much for the invitation.
And it's a strange of course,
we're all getting used to Zoom talks.
I'm still not used to them.
And I hope there are
no technical glitches.
And if there are, you'll forgive me.
I just realized as Priya was giving
me such a generous introduction,
that I don't have a
slide showing the book.
So I just want to show the book (laughs).
So, it exists.
Now I'd like to share my screen,
and the talk I'm giving tonight is
going to be a traditional PowerPoint,
but we'll let's take
more breaks than usual
because I went to the
Poorvu Center Teaching
instruction over the summer,
and one of their pieces of advice was that
the students would get bored
after about 10 minutes.
And I figure you're maybe
good for more than 10 minutes,
but anyway, there'll be a couple
of breaks during the talk.
And I wanted to start with something
Priya mentioned actually
about the main claim
of the book and the talk
I'm giving tonight about,
or this afternoon, about when
the age of discovery began,
and that most peoples,
and when I say most people
most historians answer would
be 1492 and people would talk
about Columbus and Da Gama and Magellan,
but the contention of the book
and of the talk tonight
is that the Vikings,
the Malayo-Polynesian and the
Chinese were also making long
distance ocean voyages much
earlier around the year 1000.
And the reason that this
is important is that
when the Europeans arrived
at different places around the world,
they found societies that
already had sophisticated
trading relationships with each other.
And the level of development
in those different
places helped the Europeans to penetrate
those existing markets much more quickly
than if they had arrived at
places with a blank slate.
And I wanted to start
this as a kind of classic
that this book by Richard
Evans, "In Defence of History,"
originally from 1997, a
manual that's often taught
to first year history graduate students,
even first year undergraduates
about that presents definition
of what a historical fact is.
And Evans explains that
historians use construct arguments
that are based on evidence
and the evidence consists
of different facts.
And so, and he says that a historical fact
is something that happened in
history and can be verified
as such through the traces
that history has left behind.
And historians almost always
focus on written sources
but even the early historians
like Herodotus and Polybius
and people outside of Europe,
like Sima Qian in China,
traveled to see where
the events that occurred
that they wrote about to talk to people.
Polybius has a wonderful passage
where he goes, and he looks
at the snow in the Alps
when he's trying to figure
out how an Hannibal crossed
the Alps with his elephants.
And he looks at the, he
goes and visits the Alps
to understand the conditions of the snow.
And my talk tonight is
about the unwritten traces
that history has left behind
and how historians can use them.
And I wanted to start by reminding you
where writing was first
invented around the world
and the places with the red circles,
everyone agrees that this is
the independent invention of writing.
So among the Maya in
Mexico, modern day Mexico,
in Mesopotamia, in China,
and then the case of Egypt
and Harappan India are debated
whether this was independent origin
or they were influenced
by their neighbors.
But you can see that a lot of the world
is not covered by these circles.
And if we jump to the year 1000,
which is what I'm talking about tonight,
that the there's a lot
of the world that is not,
we don't know about that.
There are no written records from,
and that's where some
new scientific techniques
have become very important
for telling us about the past.
So I'm going to start with an example.
I'm going to talk about
the Americas first,
where we have some written sources that
were actually oral
epics that were recorded
in old Icelandic, old Norse,
and then confirmed by archaeology.
And that's where the chemical
residues will come in
in terms of American trade patterns.
Then I'll talk about the
Pacific and the voyages
of the Malayo-Polynesian.
It's a mouthful, but it's
just a word for the languages
that is the ancestral
language of what becomes
modern Malay and monitoring Polynesian.
And then I'll close with the Chinese,
which is home territory for me.
I am a Chinese historian,
and for China, we have a
lot of written sources.
And so the archaeological finds are really
a supplement to those written sources.
So I begin with the Vikings,
and these voyages are described
in the Vinland Sagas, which
were transmitted orally
for several centuries
before they were written
down in the 13th and 14th centuries.
And you can see that the Vikings
or the Norse traveled from Scandinavia
to Iceland and from there
actually to Greenland
and then from Greenland they
go up, this is Baffin Island
in the Bay of Baffin, and
then travel south and land.
And we know this because of archeology,
land on the northern tip of Newfoundland
at an archaeological site
called L'Anse Aux Meadows.
So what I was going to say, we know this,
but when people first read the sagas,
they didn't know where Vinland was.
The sagas talk about a
place that was very fertile
and were wild grapes grew.
And so most people thought
that Vinland was actually
farther south than Newfoundland.
In the middle of the early,
the mid 19th century,
one scholar proposed
that Martha's Vineyard
was actually Vinland,
but in 1960, two Norwegians,
a diplomat and his archeologist wife
arrived at L'Anse Aux Meadows.
And they talk to the locals and asked them
if there were any places that
might be a Norse settlement.
And the locals brought them
to some collapsed grass
houses made out of sod and wooden timber.
And the locals thought
that they were the homes
of native Canadians, first nations peoples
but the Ingstads began to excavate there.
And they found evidence of the Norse
that I would say, I guess
I would say it was be
persuasive to other archeologists
but then they found this
bronze cloak fastening pin.
And this was really a
convincing piece of evidence
because it matched exactly
pins that had been found
like that in Iceland and Denmark.
And so we call it a diagnostic artifact.
If you find such an artifact,
it allows you to diagnose that you were
in the presence of this X
society in this case, the Norse.
And so once the Ingstads
did their excavations,
there was no question that the Norse
had arrived in Northeastern Canada
but there was a question
about how far they went.
Oh, I was gonna say, this
is one of their dwellings.
It was the biggest dwelling.
And this is where they found
other evidence of the Norse.
They found some like a needle sharpener
and a weight used in spinning.
So with that tells us
that women were with them.
And there was also a boat repair shed
where there were fragments of iron nails.
And the peoples of the
Americas were working metal
around the year 1000, but
nobody was working iron.
So we know that that was further
evidence confirming the Norse presence.
Then the question is, how
far south did the Vikings go
from Newfoundland and
conventionally people think
that they probably got to
somewhere around Maine.
There's a Viking penny was
found in Maine and the evidence
now I want to show you that
this is definitely speculative.
This is not a hard clad case,
but it's an interesting
possibility that they got
as far as the Maya Capitol
here, big city, the biggest city
in the America's probably
about 40,000 people live there.
And it was thriving right
around the year 1000.
And in Chichen Itza, which many of you
have may have visited,
this is a famous building
that people come and visit
because on the equinox,
this pattern is formed
of like the shadow of a dragon's body.
And then the shadow ends
with the head of the dragon.
So that tells you about the sophisticated
astronomy that the Maya had,
their command of astronomical knowledge.
And at Chichen Itza was a
pool called the Sacred Cenote.
And in the pool, the pool was used
for various ritual offerings
and archeologists have found things
from other places that allow us to deduce
that there was trade between
the Maya and other places.
And I'll talk about a
couple of these examples,
but basically if
archeologists find something
that they know originates
from a distant place,
they can posit that that was either
came to the place where it was found
either as a gift or a trade item.
And turquoise is one of the
distinctive things that,
distinctive items that
archeologists found in Chichen Itza.
And the it's now possible to use this
secondary ion mass
spectrometry to identify
where turquoise has
been, an individual piece
of turquoise has been mined.
That analysis hasn't been done yet
on the Mayan materials,
but this has been done
on materials in Chaco
Canyon, in New Mexico.
And it turns out that the
peoples of Chaco mined
their turquoise in a
couple of different places,
and in Chaco Canyon which many of you
may also have been to,
there were some pots.
These are very typical characteristic pots
of the Chaco peoples and
the ancestral Puebloans.
And on the bottom of these
pots were some residues.
And then when they were
analyzed using this high
performance liquid chromatography,
the scientists doing the analysis,
it was funded by Hershey Chocolate,
found the traces of liquid chocolate.
And so that allows us
to know that to conclude
that there was a trade between the Maya.
Their center is on the Yucatan peninsula.
They're the only people
who are making chocolate
in the Americas at this time,
and the peoples living in Chaco.
Also in the Sacred Cenote
where these gold objects
and these have been located as coming
from either Panama or Costa
Rica on the basis of style.
Identical artifacts have been
found in those two countries.
So that tells us that
the Maya were trading
with peoples to the south, as
well as to their northwest.
Let's go back to that
question about the Vikings
and whether or not they got
to the Yucatan peninsula.
This is a picture of The
Temple of the Warriors
at Chichen Itza, and you are not,
it's so many people go to the site
now that it's no longer possible to go in
but in 1920s and thirties there was a team
from the Carnegie Institution that based
in Washington that went
and recovered some murals.
And most of the murals look like this.
This is this scene of
invaders from one village.
And the people have been painted in gray,
the invaders, capturing the
people, the local people.
And you can see that the local
people have stripes on them.
So those may be tattooed warrior marks.
They may just be a motif that
the artist use to distinguish
between these two groups of people.
I show you this because that's
a kind of typical picture
and this is unfortunately
a watercolor copy
of an original mural that
has now been destroyed.
So all the evidence I'm going to talk
about for the next couple
of slides is secondary.
It's based, it's I think
fateful copies of materials
that once existed in the
twenties and thirties,
but then were destroyed after
they had been copied by investigators.
These are the pictures
that are quite intriguing
because they show people.
These are captives.
I'll show you how I know that,
but people in this slide,
you can see that this
person has been thrown
into the water and he's got blonde hair.
He also has beads in his hair.
And from other Mayan iconography
we know that that's how
the Mayans portrayed POW's
by putting and this he's floating there,
and then this fish is looked menacingly
as if it's about to bite his wrist.
These murals, none of these
murals, the totality they're,
I'm showing you details
because the they're so damaged.
Here's another victim.
Who's got those same beat
beads in his blonde hair.
And then here's a victim
that we can see more clearly
that he's got the blonde hair,
and he also, his arms are bound
behind him and he's been
thrown into the water.
So the question is whether
these might have been Vikings
and the, and if they were,
how did they get there?
And what a big part of
trying to figure out
who's moving around the world
in the year 1000 and how they moved,
has to do with these gyres,
the currents that are in the ocean.
And so this is a picture of all
of the gyres in the world oceans.
And then here's a detail of the gyre,
the North Atlantic gyre.
And you can see, that
if and the red gyre's
on the surface of the
water, the blue gyre,
the blue line is the deep
water under the Atlantic.
And so if someone, for example
had been blown off course,
traveling from Greenland to Newfoundland
and the sagas report that
from multiple ships were blown
off course and had
connected with the gyre,
the gyre could have
brought them ultimately
to the Yucatan peninsula.
And I warned you that
this is speculative right?
We have no hard evidence that they arrived
but it's possible the ocean
currents would have facilitated
or would, it would have
been possible to be blown
up on shore to the Yucatan peninsula.
And there's one more piece of evidence
which is I think, well,
I was gonna say my,
our late colleague Mike
Coe, the great Maya expert,
he thought this evidence
was more compelling
than the murals of the POW's
that this boat you can
see is made with planks.
And they, you can see the
outline of the planks here.
There's, nobody's shown in this picture.
This is from a different
building at Chichen Itza,
who is a Viking or a possible Viking
but so, he, Mike Coe, proposed
that this boat was captured
from the Vikings and
then the Maya used it.
And I'll just give you a comparison
so that you can see a Viking ship.
These are preserved.
This is in a museum in Norway.
And these have been these were excavated
in the late 1800's and have
been preserved remarkably well.
And there's also a legend that
a Spanish explorer heard in 1588.
And, you know, we may
or may not believe this
but when he was going on along
the coast of the Yucatan peninsula,
he met local peoples who
told him about 70 Moros.
So he's writing in Spanish
and this meaning black people,
I mean presumably from Africa.
They called their leader Xeque
which could be derived from sheik.
And then chakan is the local word
for Savannah that doesn't
have anyone living on it.
So I mentioned that again
just as the possibility
that people could be washed up on shore
and land on the Yucatan peninsula.
Okay, so let's take our first break
and see if you have any questions.
And, oh, I guess everyone is muted.
How are we, Priya help.
How are we going to do this?
- You can just unmute yourself.
- Okay.
- Yeah, so Valerie.
(mumbling)
- [Priya] We recommend that people
type questions into the chat window,
and Ty, read them out so that all of us
can hear the question.
Then we can do it efficiently.
- So I, well, I can,
Ty, would you like to read that out?
- Oh yeah sure, that's fine.
If you want to go ahead, I'll
start with the first one.
Is there any ethnobotanical evidence?
- No, not that I know of.
I mean there's ethnobotanical evidence
from L'Anse Aux Meadows about plants
that were excavated there.
I mean, there was a
very rigorous excavation
done over seven years
at L'Anse Aux Meadows.
And so for example, they
found a butter nuts there
and butter nuts don't grow locally
but they grow farther south.
And so the archeologists propose
that the Norse went farther
south, got the butter nuts
and carried them back
to L'Anse Aux Meadows.
The site of Chichen Itza
has a much more complicated
history, excavation history.
(bell dinging)
And as far as I know, there's
no ethnobotanical evidence.
- Have runes been found
anywhere in the Americas.
And then we'll get back
to the previous question.
- It's funny, there are some pseudo runes
that have been found that copy, you know,
fake runes that have been found,
but there's no genuine
runes found in North America.
(many talking)
- So Eske Willerslev, forgive me,
'cause I'm probably
mispronouncing the name
just published a paper in Nature today
on Viking genomics from
four over 400 skeletons
across Europe, Iceland and Greenland.
Are there any bones in
the Chichen Itza cenote?
- Yes, there are bones there,
but no one has done that
kind of analysis on them.
And that would be that would be,
that would be a great line of inquiry.
And that would be
definitive evidence right,
of the type that I have
not presented (laughs)
to you, that we could, if we had...
The skeletons in this
cenote are, don't just,
they date over the centuries.
But yes, if you did DNA analysis on them,
that might give us an answer to this.
And so would finding something
like the pin, that bronze
pin that I showed you.
- Are there any references
in the Norse sagas?
It seems like the kind of thing
the sagas would have recorded
if Vikings made it all the way to Mexico.
- Maybe, you know that's a good question
about what the sagas would have recorded.
And I was gonna say one
of the historians debate
the use of the sagas.
For many years, I've was teaching
with Anders Winroth who's
now sadly left Yale and gone
to the University of Oslo.
And he was consistently skeptical
about everything in the sagas.
So the sagas don't report on the Vikings
going to the anywhere distinctively
like the Yucatan peninsula.
Anders was skeptical
about the descriptions,
even of they're going to,
of locating Vinland in North America,
except for the site of
the L'Anse Aux Meadows
was so convincing to him.
And I agree with the
comment about it would only
be part of the saga if they made it back.
And yes I think the,
if the people I'm showing you were Norse
presumably they are painted as victims
who are being drowned and
then they don't survive.
Right, that's where we're seeing
them right before they die.
- Valerie, if I may ask a question.
So haven't gyres evolved.
And so were these predictions that
were made for the year 1000?
- So that's a very good question.
And I've done, I've looked
at diagrams of the currents
in different periods,
but my impression is that
the gyres are the basic direction
of the gyrus is pretty
consistent, but I will,
one thing I like about
talking to this group
is there are people here
who know more than I.
So if you know speak up, if you
know more than I do, please.
- [Shyam] The gyre going,
the current going south
is actually is indicated to be deep.
So that couldn't have helped,
would that have helped
the Vikings go south?
- I think well, there's
a couple of different,
there's the, yes, the blue
line is deep in the ocean,
but the red lines one of those
crosses the Yucatan from,
so there's a current that
crosses a lot of the Atlantic
and then touches down in
on the Yucatan peninsula.
- [Shyam] But the red
line was going north,
blue line was going south, right?
- Basically, yes.
I was gonna say let's hold onto that.
If there's time at the end,
we can go back and look at that slide.
- Yep, Valerie, are you ready to continue?
- Yes
- Please, go ahead.
- Okay, so now for part two
of this talk is about the Pacific,
and here almost everything I'm talking
about is archaeological.
And there is actually some DNA
studies also for this region
and some recent findings
from published in the summer.
And so I'm just starting with
a picture of the Pacific triangle
and the proposal that,
and this is based on
I think my next slide will, yes,
that an article
from PNAS by Janet Wilmshurst
proposing two waves of migration.
So one to the Society Islands,
and then a second wave
to these remote islands
between so to these
three, the three points
on the triangle to
Hawaii, and then Rapa Nui
to Easter Island or, and to New Zealand.
And this analysis was done on the basis
of a careful examination of
a lot of carbon-14 samples
and consciously looking at
smaller like plant lives
like leaves and twigs
as opposed to charcoal
because charcoal can live for a long time.
And the contention of Janet Wilmshurst
and her collaborators was that
the charcoal dates were misleading
'cause they suggested a the settlement
of the islands several hundred years
before the dates that she proposes.
And some of the information
we have about the settlement
of the Pacific is very
late from when James Cook,
and actually there's some
Dutch Voyagers who traveled
in the 1600's and then
James Cook in the 1770s.
And these paintings and drawings,
sketches, give us a sense
of the vessels that the
Polynesians were using at the time.
Here are the voyagers are wearing masks.
The rowers are wearing masks.
This is when they are
coming out to meet Cook.
And this is some kind of a ritual.
That's why they're holding this image here
but the pictures show two canoes
connected and then a sale.
And the...
We know from this information
from the 1700's to 1800's
that the Polynesians could
load a lot of possessions
and including animals onto the framework
between the two canoes
as they were crossing
from one Island to another.
We don't know what kind of vessel
they were using in the year 1000.
I think many people think
that they were using
this kind of vessel, but we don't know
that there hasn't been any
archaeological evidence
of the kind of vessels that they used.
And then some of the information
we have about how they did this comes
from the late 20th century
from indigenous informants.
This is a man named Mau Piailug who
had studied traditional
Polynesian seafaring as a child.
And here he's teaching it to his children.
And this allowed the Polynesians,
they basically they did
all their navigation
without any navigational instruments.
This is also true of the Vikings.
The Vikings are going shorter distances
and they can see in many cases,
they can see where they're going.
But the Polynesians are
orient themselves by looking
at the sky, looking at the
configuration of the stars.
Of course, it varies by the time of year.
It also varies by your
position in the Pacific.
And so they can memorize
these various sets of stars.
That's what Mao is teaching here
and that allowed them to orient
themselves when they were
in the ocean and they were
not near any landmasses.
And the illustration of this,
the power of this system, of
this traditional system was
that Mau was able to navigate
all the way from Hawaii
to Tahiti and his home, he's
from the area around Guam.
So he's far from home, but in this voyage,
he does this voyage for the first time.
And he navigates a craft all the way
from Hawaii to Tahiti using
this set of knowledge that
he's learned from his elders.
And so that I think is again,
we don't know for sure how
the Polynesians navigated
in this period between 1200 and 1290,
but it's very suggestive that
there's a traditional form
of navigation that allows them,
that allowed them to cover this kind
of distances in the late 20th century.
It's very plausible that
would have used it earlier.
I was going to say, there's
a funny story about Mau
that he near the end of his
life, he is blown off course,
and he's two weeks late coming home.
And his family calls the coast guard
'cause they're concerned about him.
Coast guard catches up with him and says,
basically we can we take you home?
And he said, no, no no.
I know exactly where I am.
I've been in this storm.
I've been blown off
course, but leave me alone.
I'm going to get home.
And he does, he's he shakes them off.
So the DNA report, this
was from the summer
and this was in Nature,
and there's some controversy about it.
This is where I hope maybe somebody
in the audience can help me.
The contribution of the report is that
the investigators looked
not just at Easter Island.
People have always thought
Easter Island would be the place
where there would be the most contact
between the the likeliest
site of contact between
the Polynesian islands and the
west coast of South America.
But these investigators
looked also at DNA samples
from farther north, from
the Marquesas Islands.
And that's where if you were riding
the Humboldt Current along the west coast,
going north along the west
coast of Latin America,
you would arrive
north, far north of Easter Island,
much closer to the equator.
So they have a couple of
individuals whose DNA shows
they say a specific moment of
contact, probably around 1200
which matches nicely with
that archaeological study
I told you about the carbon-14 dates
from the different plants.
And so they propose that.
And then, but this, I
think it would be, I think
more convincing if they
had ancient skeletons
or pre-1492 skeletons,
that pre-1492 DNA that allowed
them, that showed this.
So far, my understanding is
that no pre-1492 DNA samples
have surfaced that show the
mixing of the Native Americans
with, or the Native Latin
Americans with the Polynesians.
And there is some criticism
from two other investigators
who are working on this kind of
movement of ancient populations.
And they're very skeptical
about the results.
A part of this has to
do with who was moving
and whether the people who were
in Latin America had a seafaring tradition
or a boat building tradition
that would have allowed them
to go into the Pacific, or
whether it's more likely
that the Polynesians traveled all the way
from the Marquesas or Easter Island
to Latin America and back.
And this also raises the ghost of
Thor Heyerdahl who was convinced
that people had traveled
from Latin America to
the Polynesian Islands.
But I was gonna say very few
people were convinced by his
I mean, I think everybody
knew about Kon-Tiki
and his voyages, but very
few scholars were convinced
that the voyage was possible.
One of the objections is that when
he did this reconstruction of the voyage,
his raft was towed into off the coast
for about 50 miles
before he began the trip.
And so that's I was gonna say
the exploration of the Pacific.
There's another set of voyages
by these are the speakers.
So the Malayan language
is related to Polynesian
and the modern population
of Madagascar speaks
the Malagasy language,
which is related to Malay.
So there's linguistic
evidence of a connection
between the Malay
peninsula and Madagascar.
There's also cultivation of
rice and Southeast Asian crops.
And that and then here,
you can see this other set of voyages.
These took place actually
before the year 1000.
They start around 500 and they
go across the Indian ocean.
And these have been demonstrated
by careful analysis of
the plants in Madagascar
versus the plants that are
on the African mainland.
And the plants on Madagascar
have produced many more,
much more evidence of a rice diet.
The only places on the African mainland
that have comparable finds of rice
are sea coast or sea ports.
And those are presumably where people
from Asia merchants from Asia lived.
So the, I was gonna say,
this is a case where really
all of the evidence is
either archeological
or ethnohistorical is
transmitted from, you know
was used, either the
information from James Cook
or the information from the
late 20th century voyagers
or the anthropologist who studied
with them to reconstruct the mechanism
of the navigation system, the workings.
Ah, now we get to our second break.
- Thank you.
Thanks so much.
So I just wanted to
mention the reason that
we are muting, having videos muted,
is this is a recorded talk
and we would otherwise have to procure
individual release forms from everybody.
So thank you or your
patience in submitting
your questions to the chat.
Okay, so someone had
asked how did navigators
such as pow carry enough food and water?
And before you answer, we had
Professor Stearns had said
that water and gourds as
coconuts and gathered from rain,
falling on their sales is
I guess a possible answer.
Food both packed and caught,
their fish in the water all the way.
And their fluid can also be a drunk
much lower salinity than seawater.
So about the transport of food and water.
- Thank you.
I was gonna say the only thing
I would add to that is that
I was reading about Thor Heyerdahl today.
And when Kon-Tiki was doing its voyage,
the fish flying fish jumped
up and landed on the raft.
They didn't even have to
fish for them (laughs).
So, (laughing) but yes,
thank you, Steve Stearns
for that concise answer.
And anyone want to help me
with my DNA question about
the reliability of taking modern
or 20th century DNA samples
and reading back proposing a
single event occurring in 1200
whether that's plausible or reliable?
Ah, I have stunned.
I have stunned my learned audience.
- Plausible not terribly reliable.
- Okay.
- Is what has been offered in the chat.
- Oh, it's funny.
You've got more than I do.
I don't, oh, I see.
I see more.
Yeah.
Yeah, that was, that was
my read of the evidence.
And I think some of this
has to do with what we
as historians know about
movement along the coasts.
And this is one of the
objections to that report
is that we know for sure the Polynesians
are moving all around the Pacific.
We don't have evidence of the coastal
peoples in Colombia and Ecuador
sailing up and down the
coast of Latin America.
We don't think, I mean,
it's not even sure that
they had sailboats.
They probably had rafts
but it would have been very
difficult to go up and down.
And the, I showed you those
pictures from Chichen Itza
of the gold items from
Costa Rica and Panama.
Those could easily have
been carried over land.
So there's just not much
evidence of a lively,
of a tradition of ocean
travel on that side
of on the western, on the west coast,
on the northwest coast of South America.
- So another suggestion in
principle, reliable depends
on the contamination from
other biological sources
but DNA sequences are quite
idiosyncratic with low
and calculable mutation rates,
for another dimension as an answer.
- That's very helpful.
And that's what I need
to learn more about that.
So thank you very much for that Henry.
And then there's--
- new question, yeah.
What about timekeeping?
Are there similarities
in how these peoples
in contact might've kept time?
- That's a very interesting question.
The calendar is very
important and calendars move,
good calendars move right?
People in the past really want to know
when is the right time to plant crops
or when, when eclipses are going to come.
It's I write about in my book
that one of the big questions
in east Asia, actually
1052 was about people
thought the end, Buddhist believe
that the end of the world was coming.
And there were some eclipse predictions
and people who could
predict accurate eclipses
or almanacs that had good
eclipse data were extremely valuable.
And people went to great
lengths to try to import them.
I was going to say also looking at the Q&A
that someone asked about the anthropology
of the Argonauts of the Western
Pacific since Melonovski.
No, but I will thank
you for the suggestion.
So should we go back to
the last part of the talk?
I'll go, and it's about
China and it's short,
'cause as I told you there
isn't too much science
it's mostly historical records.
So I just wanted to start
with a slide of this route
which was the main sea corridor
that was in use before 1492
and continued to be used after 1492.
And it connected the
ports of Southeast China
with the Persian Gulf
ports especially Basra,
which was the closest port to Baghdad.
And also you can see Oman,
and the...
this there's a lot
of Chinese sources that
describe this route.
There's the maps of the region.
This is, I wanted to just explain to you
that the reason the
Chinese are going there is
that they want to import these different
aromatics from Southeast Asian.
Aromatic is catch word use.
The Chinese word is xiang,
meaning fragrant items.
And these include things like sandalwood.
They include spices, like cloves.
They're some natural products.
These aren't necessarily aromatics
but like the, the feathers
of the King Fisher bird
were, the Chinese valued very much.
And when I tell you about
these things, you can think,
oh well, the Chinese were importing those.
They couldn't have been that important
but the society in China, and we know this
from around the year 1000,
and then the use of explodes
in the next couple of centuries.
People are consumed with trying to change
the way that they smell
and the way that the air
in their houses smell.
And they burn a lot of
different kinds of instance
and fragrant woods to try
to change their environment.
And the, so those goods are,
the Chinese are importing
in large quantities
and mostly from Southeast Asia,
but some of them also come
from India and come from
the Arabian peninsula.
What the Chinese are selling,
they've got ceramics.
This is a classic example,
and so this is a slide
from my teaching about the
iPhone of the year, 1000.
The thing the item that
everybody had to have
was a high fired, translucent ceramic pot.
They were very easy to clean
and much easier to clean than pots made
in other parts of the world
that were not fired as high.
The Chinese are also
exporting metals, ingots,
and so ingots of copper and tin.
They're making metal objects
like cauldrons and woks
and mirrors, also some
weapons, but we actually don't,
the Chinese are using a lot
of those weapons within China.
We don't have much evidence
of their exporting them,
and high quality fabrics,
both cottons and silks.
And we have much more
archaeological evidence about
the ceramics than we do about
the metals or the textiles.
And the main thing that
the archaeology tells us
that the written records
don't is the quantity.
So we have descriptions of ships
leaving China that are carrying ceramics
but we have archaeological sites.
One, ship found in Indonesian waters,
one shipwreck found in Indonesian waters
has 600,000 pots were found onboard.
It's just a quantity
that the written sources
just give no hint of.
And this, we also have some shipwrecks
the actual ships that survived.
This one is in a Chinese museum.
And it's interesting
because it has repair.
So you can see the Chinese made this
with planking like the Vikings did, right?
They're different kinds.
It's a different construction,
but there's and then the Chinese ships
had distinct compartments.
My next slide will make that clearer.
No, it won't, sorry.
I cut that slide because of time.
The Chinese ships had
distinct compartments,
separate compartments,
and those meant that,
they could, that question
we had before about water,
they could travel with a compartment that
was filled with fresh water
and they also sometimes
traveled with a compartment
filled with seawater,
where they had fish living in the water
they could kill when they wanted to.
But the real advantage of
those discreet compartments was
that if the ship sprang a
leak, the leak was contained
in that one area and not in the whole,
it didn't affect the whole ship.
In my talk title, I mentioned LIDAR
and the contribution of
LIDAR to our understanding
really of Southeast Asia is that,
and you can see here that
this is the same place.
This Ta Prohm Temple in Angkor Wat,
and when you visit it, you
see all these trees around it.
And it would be, it was very difficult
for archeologists to know whether
basically what the terrain looked like,
what the surface looked like
'cause there was so much
undergrowth in this tropical forest,
and here is a LIDAR picture that,
so this is taken by bombarding the ground
with rays and then editing
them, filtering them out.
And so anything that bounces back
from a plant is filtered out.
And so that archeologists can
see the surface of the land.
And the real surprise from
Angkor Wat was how many
of these, what are now open spaces
or a forest had spaces historically
contained many, many dwellings.
And the upshot is that
Angkor Wat's population,
the estimate has been increased
to about 750,000 people
which is far higher than
what was previously thought.
And there's nothing, there's
no information like that in any
of the written Chinese sources
about Cambodia at this time.
And then the last slide
about the Chinese is
showing you this route
that they traveled and the
distances that they covered.
I mean in some ways the I'm going to apply
that the farther people went,
I mean the more impressive it was
but in fact, cutting directly
across here saved quite a lot
of miles and that this route
all the way from Guangzhou
to Basra and then down to, Sofala,
south to Sofala, this is about three times
the length of Columbus's voyages.
So...
I was gonna say just in
terms of the distances
that were traveled, some of
the voyages that take place
in what we conventionally call the age
of exploration were not that much longer.
Columbus's voyages were on a par
with those of the Malayo-Polynesians,
and actually shorter than those that
the Chinese were traveling
as they went from.
And when I say the Chinese,
other peoples, Indian,
other peoples in the Indian
ocean are also voyaging
from the Islamic world
and India towards China.
And so Da Gama's voyage where
he circumnavigates Africa,
even he is not going
farther than the Chinese.
Magellan, yes.
Magellan goes around with his
crew, he gets killed right,
in a rebellion in the Philippines,
but Magellan circumnavigates the world.
And so, but I was going to say
the reason that we pay so much attention
to the later voyages is that
we know about their impact,
that they had any nearly immediate
and far reaching consequences.
There were many of the
people living in the Americas
were killed by either the
common cold or flu or smallpox.
And once America had been
emptied of the indigenous
of many of the indigenous
peoples, then European settlers
and African slaves
moved into the new world
and there was the creation
of the triangle trade.
So I mean, that's a huge impact.
And the voyage is I'm talking
about in the year 1000
or around the year 1000, the
impact is not as immediate.
It's not as obvious but
they did affect people
who were living in different regions.
And so the Vikings don't have
much impact on North America.
They pull out after about 10 years,
but they traveled east into
Russia and the Ukraine.
This was discussed in that article
in the New York Times
yesterday about the DNA.
And they built the first empires
in the Russ empire is
the product of Vikings who have
or Swedes who have come, mostly Swedes,
people living in modern
Sweden who have come
into modern day Russia and Ukraine
and create the Russ state.
All of the Pacific and
Madagascar gets settled
by the Polynesian voyages,
so that's very clear impact.
And the Chinese economy becomes
very heavily intertwined
with that of Southeast Asia
so much so that we have people who had
been working the land in China
who shift to working full
time in ceramics factories.
And we have forest peoples
in Southeast Asia who
you know, traditionally
were hunting and gathering
and they start to hunt
and gather full time
for specific animals like
those Kingfisher birds
I told you about the Chinese want.
So and all of this economic activity from,
and these connections that
are formed in the year 1000,
contribute to the connecting
up of the world in,
the further connecting
up of the world in 1500.
I began by asking or saying
I was gonna talk about
the historian's toolbox.
And I think the toolbox has
changed that historians are,
have to look at DNA and
ocean currents and LIDAR
and the residues of the
chocolate in ceramic vessels.
Do I think historians are
going to give up documents?
No (chuckles).
I mean, part of it is that we
have, as we get closer in time
to the present, we have so
much more documentary material
and so much more coverage
and the documents have the great virtue,
all the things I've been talking about,
don't really, they allow us to see some
of these changes or do
identify some of these changes
but they don't allow us
to know how anybody felt
about anything or what
the experience was like.
And so, I think it's very important
as we try to understand the
history of the whole world
and all the different regions
of the world that we use
every technology we can
to reconstruct the past
that's lost to us, but
I think there's still
pleasures or insights to be,
pleasures from studying,
insights to be derived
from studying these documents.
It's documents that at least
so far, these scientific traces
and scientific testing techniques
don't allow us to get at.
Thank you very much.
- [Priya] Standing in as a proxy applause.
I will try to actually unmute everybody
so that at the end, they can
give you a round of applause,
but I think we can move to questions now.
So please go ahead and start.
- Okay.
First one, have you looked at
the China porcelain trade to East Africa?
- A little bit?
There's a very fine scholar who works
in that field named
(mumbling) and who's French.
She's working in France now,
and she's, and the Chinese have been
excavating in East Africa.
And so we can see, those finds
have been well published.
We can see the different kinds of pots
that were traded that made it
all the way to East Africa.
And the one of the things
about Chinese ceramics,
and are there's a curator
at the Yale Art Gallery
named Denise Leidy, Dr.
Denise Leidy, who's an expert
in this field is that when
Chinese ceramics scholars
look at a piece of a pot or the whole pot
they can tell which kiln it
was made, where it was made.
And so that's very helpful
in terms of reconstructing
the sources of these ceramics
and figuring out where
they came from in China,
and then how they traveled
all the way to East Africa.
Chinese cartographic tradition.
Yes, there was a Chinese
cardiographic tradition.
I mean it is a broad generalization.
I'd say that there's more
maps of domestic China
than there are of
countries outside of China,
but there are some and one of the things,
the Beinecke has a terrific map
of the Chinese coast that
I've been looking at.
It's been scanned because of COVID.
And so I have a color copy of it.
And the...
Should I read out these questions?
I'm looking at these are
from Tim Wyscoll about--
- That'd be great for the recording.
He asked about the Chinese
porcelain trade to East Africa
and the Chinese cartographic tradition,
and then Gavin Menzies,
the author of a book called "1421",
which I did not mention.
I have to say, I don't know
any card-carrying Chinese
historian who thinks that
anything in 1421 is believable.
So, and he claimed that he had
pre-Colombian Chinese maps of the Pacific,
but in fact, he had post-Colombian maps
or you know, he was using later maps
and then had a very convoluted argument
about how they could use these.
His argument was these maps
from the 1500's were actually
based on information that
was circulating before 1500
but I think any serious
historian would say no,
that information was not
available before 1500.
- Thank you.
A participant would like
to know what about the role
of the Indian Ocean currents
for the, sorry, I just lost it.
Do you see it there?
- Yeah, for Madagascar being populated
by the Indonesians.
- Indonesians, thank you.
- It's funny.
It's, they help, and then of course,
the real problem is that it's very hard
to sail from Africa to Madagascar
that with the ocean currents.
So, I mean that's the real obstacle.
I mean, it seems so counterintuitive
when you look at a map
that the first people to get
to Madagascar would've come
from the Malay peninsula
and not from Africa
but that is indeed the case.
And we know that archaeologically
because of this evidence
of the many, many different plants
and many multiple sites
where they found the evidence
of the rice and other
Asian crops on Madagascar
and then a different set of more
typical African crops on Africa.
- From one of our new Franke Fellows.
When you set out to write this book,
did you know that, did you know then that
you'd need to expand your
toolkit beyond texts?
And how did your method
develop through the course
of your research to
engage different methods
such as archaeology, LIDAR, et cetera?
- Thank you for the question.
Two of the maps I showed
are from a world history
textbook that I wrote co-wrote with,
my coauthor's named Ken Curtis.
And when he and I started
to write that book
I didn't realize how important
these other different,
these other methods, these
scientific methods would be.
And then as we were working on that book
and it took a long time,
I've realized that, you know,
it was because for the mandate
of a world history textbook
is each part of the world
gets its own chapter, right?
You're not allowed to say,
oh, I can't write anything
about Southeast Asia 'cause
we don't know anything.
You have to find out what we know.
So that's when I started
to expand my toolkit
beyond texts, and I was always
interested in archaeology.
I, in high school, I was
interested in archaeology
and actually my earlier research
I'm interested in excavated texts.
So texts, that in the ground,
that archeologists find.
We have such a long
transmitted historical record
from China, but we have
very few texts that survive
in the condition that they were written
in, and then we can look at them today.
And those are the things that I still find
very compelling.
- And follow--
(Valerie mumbling)
- I was just going to say one more thing
about the research method is, you know
Yale is a great place in so many ways,
but I've just found out
if I wanted to find out
about different kinds of technologies
or science technologies
that I don't know about,
that I could go talk to colleagues
and they would very generously
tell me what to read
or explain things to me
when I read what they,
when I did my reading and
I still didn't understand,
they would patiently explain to me.
- Have you followed the early Dutch
cartographic history of South Asia?
- No, but I think it'll
be interesting, you know,
but it's I was gonna say one
of the interesting things
about the post-1492 cartographic history
is how quickly the discoveries,
the knowledge moves
around the world, right.
Once people have mapped the
correct, the accurate outlines
or even inaccurate outlines,
that information is spreading
'cause everybody wants that information.
- So I had a related question,
Valerie, which is, you know
what do you think having
studied these earlier voyages?
What is distinctive about the encounters?
You know, the colonial encounters that
happen later on, is it just the scale?
Is it because, or where there, were these
peoples when they were moving and trading,
did they try to conquer
each other already?
And we just don't know.
And I'm just wondering, you
know, that colonial impulse
right, seems to have
really come to the fore
in the you know, 14,
1500's later on, right?
And I was curious whether you wondered
was there something different?
As you said, maybe is it
because there is information,
Europe is then by then
information transmission
within Europe is very rapid
and things have really shifted
in Europe by then, or...
- That's part of the story.
I was gonna say one of the
things that European historians
talk about which I think
is very interesting
is the idea of a colony.
There's a whole bunch of
Chinese historians who would say
oh, when the Chinese get someplace new
they don't have this
desire to form a colony,
and that can be a very
rosy view of the Chinese.
And they certainly
meddled in local politics
and even overthrew princes
and replaced them with
their own candidates.
But they didn't seem to have an idea
that you go to someplace new that if it's
contiguous with China, then
you can add it to China.
But if you go to someplace,
that's not contiguous
with China, there seemed to
just like, leave it alone.
They would like that the local ruler
to acknowledge the Chinese ruler.
The Europeans have this model of a colony.
And, you know, there's
Roman colonies right?
That goes way back.
But there is been some
very interesting work about
the Crusades and the crusader
colonies in the Mediterranean.
So that's part of the answer
is what's going on in Europe.
And when the Columbus gets to Hispaniola,
how he made his first
instinct is to claim it
for Ferdinand and Isabelle, right.
He's not where I think the
people I'm talking about,
they might've landed but I don't think
their first impulse is to
claim it for any ruler.
And then I think a key factor
and especially significant today,
thinking about COVID is this the role that
disease played when the
Europeans arrived in the Americas
and the catastrophic consequences
it had on the local population.
- Right.
So I see a comment on
the chat where, you know,
colonialism is not an artifact
of European expansion,
but you know, the Greeks and Phoenicians
are also European incidentally.
So they're giving me some--
- And I mentioned the Romans too, right?
It's not, yes, I agree.
Colonialism was not an
artifact of European expansion.
I think the interesting question
is where does it come from?
- Has it come from, and
when does it start, right?
So, because it's a point in
time where we can see this kind
of notion of a colony
develop and ripen as it were, right.
And I think the Crusades
have a lot to do with that.
I mean, the crusader
states in the Holy Land
and then when they're forced to withdraw
when Saladin defeats them,
and they withdraw to Cyprus, right?
That argument I find very compelling
about the idea of colonies going back.
I mean, there are earlier precedents,
but that I think you can
draw a continuous line
from the Crusader colonies
in the Mediterranean to some
of the colonies in the
Atlantic, like Madeira
or the Canary islands and
then to the Americans.
- Thank you.
- I'm looking at the question.
We haven't talked about slavery at all.
I have a lot about slavery in the book.
There's a lot of slavery.
It goes way back in time.
I think it probably was the
norm in almost every society.
And I haven't, I hope I
haven't said anything to imply
that it didn't exist in the past.
It was...
- Right.
No no.
I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit
because you do have quite
a lot of it in the book
and, you know Wilkerson's
new book kind of tries
to make the claim that
there's a particular way
in which slavery gets
configured that, you know,
goes back to 1619, and the slaves,
African slaves coming to America.
And I was just curious,
because in your book
you do talk about the fact
that the notion of slaves
is around for a very long time right?
So would like to, more about from you.
- I mean, I think the, I
haven't read Wilkerson's book.
The to me, the what's distinctive about
slavery in the Americas after 1600
is the demographic change
that the indigenous people
have been wiped out to such a large extent
and that the population is
replaced with the African slaves.
All of the examples I'm talking about are
slaves are a source of labor.
And also in many cases, more importantly,
a source of children.
There's "The Cambridge World
History of Slavery, Volume Two"
which is about the medieval
period is about to come out.
And I was lucky enough
to see the page proofs
and in many societies around the world
there are more women slaves
than there are male slaves.
So that you know that and
scholars of slavery work on this.
My colleague Ed Rugemer
is one of the people that
they're aware of, there's a lot of variety
for in how slaves are
used in different places.
In the year 1000, any society that
doesn't have enough goods to export
starts exporting either its people
or people it's captured
from its neighbors.
So it's just the world is short of labor
and everybody will pay money for it.
So it's a very appealing commodity,
a grim, grim as this is to us today.
- A participant contributes.
The question is not one of colonies,
but one of frontiers,
a great deal is known.
Sorry, a great deal is known
about trading frontiers.
Just pulling it up here.
As a source of tension I think,
with trading communities leading
to new forms of conquest.
- Well I go back to what I said.
When Columbus lands on
Hispaniola, he already has an idea
that he wants that territory for Spain.
- Yes.
I mean, so, you know,
there's no prequel to that,
his decision, his desire
to somehow claim that land.
And there's a suggestion of a book
that looks very interesting.
"Commerce and Cartography
on Colonial Frontiers,"
"Re-examining American and
African History Through Maps",
which I haven't looked
at, but I definitely will.
- Yeah, it sounds really interesting.
I'm hoping because it says maps as well.
Are there any other
questions please feel free
to type them in the chat?
If not, I might chime in
and ask one more question.
So when you showed in the earliest part
of your talk about these independent
places where languages are
believed to have originated,
I say, I know you said that you know,
the Harappan language is
yet to be deciphered, right.
We don't know.
And I wonder the fact that we have not
been able to decipher it having
deciphered the other ones,
can that count as some kind of evidence
for independent generation?
- Oh, well I think, I
mean, there are debates.
There's a fascinating discussion
about the Harappan script.
And basically there are too many elements.
I think there were about 400 elements
in the Harappan script.
So too many for an alphabet,
but too few for pictorial script.
- Right.
(Valerie laughs)
- Right, so that's very interesting.
You know, is it...
I hate to say, we're never
going to decipher it.
- Right.
- You know, that may be one
of those problems that
somebody figures out
and you know, I mean I was
gonna say the Maya script
defied (mumbling) for so long.
And then, you know, this kind of basic,
I mean I think there was a coincidence
of certain kinds of information
that people had discounted.
And then other people came along
and said, oh, you know what?
This is could be a key
piece of information.
Some reports from Spanish,
the Spanish who had contact
with the Meyer early on
and saw them writing.
And so that information and
then I think also this key idea
which came from, I think
knowing about Japanese,
that you can write the same word
in like five different ways, right?
So a decipherer's nightmare
that the same word
can be written in so many ways.
So anyway, that's why you know,
I had the Harappan script in
a different category whether--
- What I found really
fascinating to imagine
from reading your book and listening
to you today was, you
know, the imagination
of what these encounters,
when these people showed up,
like how did they even
communicate with each other?
How would that have looked like?
I wonder if you have sort of imagined
and speculated and what
this might've been like.
- I mean, I think that
the Vinland Sagas are,
give us the best help on that
because they describe
people meeting and looking
at what each other are carrying, right.
And gesturing to trade.
And then there's also that great passage
in the Vinland Sagas
where there's an encounter
between a woman, a Norse woman,
and a local, an indigenous woman.
And the Norse woman says,
you know, my name is
I think it's Gertrude.
And that a local woman says,
oh, my name is Gertrude.
And you think that it makes no sense
and it does 'cause she's just
repeating what she hears.
Right?
- Wow.
- So that that would be the logical thing.
You've just, when you're start to work
on somebody's language, they
say something, you say it back
and then you start building
up these sentences.
- Evidence that women
were on these voyages too?
- Yes, there is.
And there's archaeological evidence
for both the Polynesians and the Vikings.
The Viking evidence is we
have the a needle sharpener
and also a weight that was used for,
to hold the yarn down
when you were spinning it.
And we also, in the sagas,
they talk about women.
There's a woman who is quite feisty,
and she bears she gets into
a fight with the local people
and she bears her breast and
slaps it with her, a dagger.
And they all run away the source tells us,
appalled by her behavior or
terrified by her behavior.
So, and then for the Polynesians,
we know women are there
because the Polynesians multiply.
That you know, if it had been all men,
they would have landed on the islands
and died after a certain amount of time,
but they have children and
the population gets going.
So we know that women are
on those voyages, too.
- Wow.
I think there's another
suggestion for another book.
(laughing)
- [Man] Is chocolate and Chaco
Canyon just a coincidence?
(laughing)
- No, no it's not.
That's trade between,
there's sustained trade
between Chaco Canyon and the Maya.
We've got the chocolate
going from the Maya north.
We also have I didn't mention this
'cause of time macaw feathers.
So we have these brightly
colored green and red feathers
and we've got feather tapestries that
have been found that
have these macaw feathers
in them that date to around the year 1000.
We also have sadly birdcages
in which there are dead macaw skeletons
and the skeletons were malnourished.
And they had as if they had been
kept inside and not fed enough.
So there's definitely a two way trade
between Chaco Canyon and Chichen Itza.
- Any other questions?
If not, let's thank
Valerie for a fantastic,
thought provoking talk.
And I'll just, I think we
should unmute everybody
so that we can give her
a round of applause.
(clapping)